c'était à maman elle arrive je te
présente sa petite soeur elle
s'appellera le mirail ça veut dire
l'avenir tu seras gentil avec elle tu la
protèges à un moment j'étais quand
j'étais bébé tu étais comme mirail je
n'aime pas ne l'attend pas je t'ai dit
d'être gentil avec elle aux frères rate
de mettre des trucs sur la figure tu me
tape dessus tu me tord les joues tu me
fait pleurer tu es mirail de l'avenir
n'était pas gentil avec maman
je vais te dire exactement ce que tu
ressens ce coma tu es jaloux c'est tout
vous je suis le prince mon cher
tu veux aussi faire de mon mieux pour
élever mes enfants et tout ce que je
fais c'est énervé après tu aimes plus
miral que moi c'est vraiment pas juste
j'en assume
[Musique]
je viens de
tu vas voir je vais t'emmener en
promenade et à prendre le nom de tous
les internes
[Musique]
et
pour tous ces moments fugaces évidemment
qu'ils nous ont créé fond ce que nous
sommes aujourd'hui
[Musique]